today we want to look at the sum-product
problem so for the past few lectures
we've been discussing the structure of
sets under the addition operation today
we're going to throw in one extra
operation as a multiplication and
understand how sis behaved under both
addition and multiplication and the
basic problem here is can it be the case
that a plus a and a times a which is
analogously the set of all pairwise
products of elements from a can these
two sets be simultaneously small are the
same for some single a can we have it so
that a plus a and a times they are
simultaneously small for example it's
easy to make one of them small we've
seen examples where if you take a to be
an arithmetic progression then a plus a
is more or less as small as it gets but
for such an example you see a times a is
pretty large it's actually not so clear
how to proof how large it is and there's
some very nice proofs and this problem
has actually been more or less pinned
down but the short version is that a
time say has size close to its maximum
possible so it turns out the size of a
times a is almost quadratic okay so this
number it's actually now known fairly
precisely so this problem of determining
the size of a times a for the interval 1
to n is known as the errors
multiplication table problem
so if you take a n by n multiplication
table how many numbers do you see in the
table so that's turns out to be subcode
Radek but not two sub-quadratic okay so
the sensor has been so this problem has
been more or less solved by Kevin Ford
and we now know a fairly precise
expression but I don't want to focus on
that that's not the topic of today's
lecture this is just an example
alternatively you can take a time say to
be quite small by taking a to be a
geometric progression then it's not too
hard to convince yourself that a plus a
must be fairly large in that case the
geometric progression doesn't have so
much additive structure so a plus a will
be large so can you make a plus a and a
times a simultaneously small so this is
conjectured that the answer is no and
this is a famous conjecture in this area
known as the Irish similarity conjecture
on the sum-product problem which states
that for all finite sets of real numbers
either a plus a or a times a has to be
close to quadratic size
so that's the conjecture is still very
much open today I want to show you some
progress towards this conjecture here
some partial results and it will use a
nice combination of tools from graph
theory and incidence geometry so nicely
ties in together many of the things that
we've seen in this course so far so
erudition similarity proved some bound
which is like 1 plus C for some constant
C today we'll show some bounds form
somewhat better C's so you see the first
tool that I want to introduce this a
result from graph theory known as the
crossing number inequality so you know
that planar graphs are graphs where you
can draw on the plane so that the edges
do not cross and there are some famous
examples of non planar graphs like K 5
and K 3 3 but you can ask a more
quantitative question if I give you a
graph how many crossings must you have
in every drawing of this graph and the
crossing number inequality provides some
estimate for such a quantity so given a
graph G going to know by C R so crossing
of G to be the minimum number of
crossings in a planar drawing of G
there's a bit of subtlety here where by
a planar drawing do I mean using line
segments or do I mean using curves
sorry not clear how they affect this
quantity here that's a very subtle issue
so for planar graphs
there's a famous result that more or
less s if a planar graph can be drawn
using continuous curves then can be
drawn using straight lines but the
minimum number of crossings the two
different ways of drawing stay might end
up with different cross
numbers but for the purpose of today's
lecture we'll use a more general notion
although it doesn't actually matter for
today which one we'll use so planar
drawing using curves draw the graph
where edges are continuous curves
how many crossings do you get the
crossing is a pair of edges that cross
you can pair I just a cross or a point
that can it doesn't matter so there are
many different subtle ways of defining
all these things they won't really come
up for today's lecture the crossing
number inequality it's a result from the
80s which gives you a lower bound
estimate on the number of crossings if G
is a graph with enough edges the number
of edges is let's say at least four
times the number of vertices then the
crossing the number of crossings of
every drawing of G is at least the
number of edges cubed divided by the
number of vertices
squared and there's an extra constant
factor which you know it's just some
constant
after the constant does not depend on
the graph so in particular it has a lot
of edges then G every drawing of G must
have a lot of crossings okay so the
crossing number inequality was proved by
two separate independent works one by a
I thought all newborns am ready and the
other by Tom Leighton our very own Tom
Leighton here ok so let me first give
you some consequences of the theorem
just for illustration so if you have an
N vertex graph with a quadratic number
of edges
then how many crossings must you have
you plug in these parameters into the
theorem see that it has necessarily and
to the four crossings well if you just
draw the graph in some arbitrary way you
have at most n to the four crossings
because the crossing involves four
points okay so when you have a quadratic
number of edges you must get basically
the maximum number of crossings the
leading constant four-term factor is an
interesting problem which we're not
going to get it let's prove the crossing
number inequality first be the base case
of the crossing number inequality is
when you can draw a graph with no
crossings and those are planar graphs so
for every connected planar graph if it
has at least one cycle you see why in
the second wire say this if with at
least one cycle so that's not a tree we
must have that three times the number of
faces yes at most two times the number
of edges okay so here we're gonna use
the key cooping winners formula we all
know as the number of vertices minus a
number of edges plus a number of faces
equals to two we're here for face draw
draw a planar graph so I count the faces
here there are two faces outer face in
your face
come edges and vertices so you have
Oilers formula up there and plug in
where this formula for a planar graph
least one cycle okay so we can obtain
this consequence over here because
every face is adjacent to at least three
edges if you go around the face you see
at least three edges and every edge is
counted exactly twice adjacent to
exactly two faces so you do the double
counting you get that inequality up
there okay so plugging these two into
Euler gets you that inequality up there
plug it plug in these two into Euler we
get we got that the number of edges is
that most three times the number of
vertices minus six so so this that
inequality by plug it into allure you
get you can in this in Tooele you get
this so we have that a number of edges
it's at most three times the number of
vertices for every graph G here we're
required that the graph is planar and
has at least one cycle but even if we
drop the planet even if we drop the
condition has at least one cycle but
just require that this planar every
graph G status every planar graph G
satisfies this inequality over here so
in other words fact amount of heard
before in a planar graph the average
degree of a vertex is at most six so in
particular the crossing number of a
graph G is positive if the number of
edges exceeds three times the number of
vertices it's not planar so as at least
one crossing every drawing
and by deleting an edge from each
drawing from each crossing we get a
planar graph draw the graph you have
some crossings you get rid of an edge
associated to each drawing then you get
a planar graph you look at this
inequality and you count for the number
of edges that you deleted we obtained
then the inequality that the number of
edges minus a number of crossings is at
least three times the number of vertices
so we obtain the inequality that blower
bound the number of crossings as number
of edges minus three times the number of
vertices
okay so that's some lower bound on the
crossing number it's not quite a band
that we have over there and in fact if
you take a graph with a quadratic number
of edges this bound here only gives you
quadratic lower bound on the crossing
number some lower bound but it's not a
great lower bound and we would like to
do better so here's a trick that this is
a very nice trick where we're going to
use this inequality to upgrade it to a
much better inequality at a bootstrapper
to a much tighter inequality so this
involves the use of the probabilistic
method I need to note by P some number
between zero and one to be decided later
and starting with a graph G let's let G
prime address being vertices and edges
being V Prime and E prime be obtained
from G by randomly the leading sum of
the edge of some of the vertices or
rather randomly keeping each vertex with
probability P independently for each of
these vertices so you have some graph G
I keep each vertex with probability P
and I delete the remaining vertices and
I get a smaller graph I guess I'm
induced subgraph and I would like to
know what can we say about the crossing
number of the smaller graph in
comparison to the crossing number of the
original graph well for the smaller
graph because it's still a planar graph
like so G prime so it's it's still graph
it's not now playing about it's still
graph so G prime still satisfies this
inequality up here
so G Prime still satisfies that the
number of crossings and every drawing of
G prime is at least the number of edges
of G prime minus three times the number
of vertices of G Prime
but now note that G prime is a random
graph G was fixed given G prime is a
random graph so let's evaluate the
expectation of both quantities left-hand
side and right-hand side if this
inequality is true for every G prime the
same inequality must be true in
expectation now what do we know about
the expectations of each of these
quantities the number of vertices in
expectation that's pretty easy so this
one here is P times the original number
of vertices the number of edges is also
pretty easy each edge is kept if both
endpoints are kept so this expectation
on a number of edges remaining it's also
pretty easy to determine the crossing
number of the new graph well that I have
to be still bit more careful off because
when you look at this smaller graph
maybe there's a different way to draw it
that's not just deleting these some of
the vertices from the original graph so
even though the original graph might
have a lot of crossings when you go to a
sub graph maybe there's a better way to
draw it but we just need an inequality
in the right direction so we are still
okay and I claim that the crossing
number of G prime is in expectation at
most P to the 4 times the crossing
number of G because if you keep the same
drawing
then the expected number of crossings
that are kept so each crossing is kept
if all four of its endpoints are kept so
each crossing is kept with probability P
to the fourth you can draw it in
expectation with this many crossings
maybe it's much less maybe there's a
better way to draw it but you have an
inequality going in the right direction
okay looking at that inequality up there
in yellow we find that the crossing
number of G is at least P to the minus 2
e minus P 3 P to the minus 3 and this is
true for every value of P between 0 & 1
so now you pick a value of P that works
most in your favor and it turns out you
should do this by setting these two
quantities to be roughly equal to each
other so setting P between 0 & 1 so that
for x basically set these two terms to
be roughly equal to each other and then
we get that this quantity here is at
least the claimed quantity which is the
cubed over the squared up to some
constant factor which I don't really
care about in order to set P I have to
be a little bit careful that peace
between 0 & 1 if you set P to be one
point two this whole argument doesn't
make any sense so so this is okay
okay so meaning keys at most one ass
long ass yes at most for I mean the four
here is not optimal but if for War two
then it's not true right so if yes to
view you can have a planar graph so you
shouldn't have a lower bound on the
crossing number okay so this is the
proof of the crossing number inequality
which says that if you have lots of
edges then you must have lots of
crossings any questions okay so let's
use the crossing number inequality to
prove a fundamental result in incidence
geometry so incidence geometry is this
area of discrete math that concerns
fairly basic sounding questions about
incidences between let's say points and
lines and here's an example what's the
maximum number of incidences between
endpoints and end lines where by
incidence I mean if P so curly P is a
set of points and curly L is the set of
lines then I write I of P and L to be
the number of pairs one point one line
such that the point lies on the line so
I'm counting incidences between points
and lines you can view this in many ways
you can view it as a bipartite graph
between points and lines and we're
counting a number of edges in this
bipartite graph like if you end points
and lines what's the maximum number of
incidences it's not such an obvious
question so let's see how we can
approach this question but first let me
give you some easy bounds right so so
here's a trivial bound so here I want to
know if I give you some number of points
some number of lines what's the maximum
number of incidences
so if trivial bound yes
remember incidences is at most the
product between the number of points and
the number of lines I'm pointing online
and most one incidence okay so that's
pretty trivial we can do better so we
can do better because well you see let's
use this following fact that every line
so every pair of points determine at
most one line I have two points there's
almost one line that contains those two
points using this fact we see that the
number of so let's count the number of
triples involving two points and one
line such that both points lie on the
line okay so how big can this set be so
let's try to count it in two different
ways on one hand this quantity is that
most the number of points squared
because if I give you two points then
they determine this line so the most
number of points squared but on the
other hand we see that if I give you a
line I just need to count now the number
of so and we also require that these two
points are distinct right so if I give
you a line
I don't just need to count the number of
pairs of points on this line so I can
enumerate over lines and count line by
line how many pairs of points are on
that line so I get this quantity over
here on each line I have that
contribution and now you saying
cauchy-schwarz inequality we find that
this squared term is at least the number
of intended incidences divided by the
number of lines and the remaining minus
one term contributes just to the number
of incidences so the first is by Cauchy
Schwartz
so putting these two inequalities
together we get some bound some upper
bound on the number of incidences if you
have to invert this inequality you will
get that the number of incidences
between points and lines is upper
bounded by the number of points times
the number of lines raised to power 1/2
plus the number of lines so that's what
you get from this inequality over here
by considering point line duality so you
whenever you have this kind of set up
involving points and lines you can take
the projected duality and transform the
configuration into lines into points and
points into lines and incidences are
preserved so I also have an inequality I
also have an inequality where I switch
the rows of points and lines so I is
already the numbers I don't need to put
an extra absolute the number of points
and lines is upper bounded by the number
of lines times the square root of the
number of points plus an extra term just
in case there are very few lines okay so
these are the balance that you have so
far and the only thing that we have used
so far is the fact that every two points
determine at most one line and every two
lines meter and most one point so these
are the bounds that we get and in
particular for endpoints and end lines
we get that the number of incidences is
Big O of n to the
this should remind you of something
we've done before so in first part of
this course when we were looking at
extremal numbers where did three-halves
come up c4 yeah so if you compare this
quantity to the extremal number of c4
it's also m to the three-halves and in
fact the proof is exactly the same all
we're using here is that the incidence
graph is C for free in fact this is an
argument about C for free graphs so this
fact here up every two points determine
the most one line it's saying that
there's no if you look at the incidence
graph there's no C form so that's all
we're using for now any questions all
right so is this the truth now back when
we were discussing the extremal number
for C for free graphs we saw that in
fact this is the correct water and what
was the construction there so the
construction also came from incidences
but incidences of taking all lines and
points in the finite field playing an F
Q squared if you look at old lines and
all the points in a finite field plane
then you get the correct lower bound for
C form but now we are actually working
in the real plane so it turns out that
the answer is different when you're not
working the finite field we're going to
be using the topology of the real plane
and we're going to come up with a
different answer so it turns out that
the truth for the number of maximum
number of incidences in the plane for
points and lines
in the real plane is not exponent
three-halves but turns out to be 4/3 and
this is a consequence of an important
result in incidence geometry a
fundamental result known as
dissimilarity Trotters their similarity
trotter theorem says that the number of
incidences between points and lines is
upper bounded by this function where you
look at a number of points times the
number of lines and each raised to power
2/3 and plus some additional terms just
in case there are many more lines
compared to points or way more points
compared to lines okay so that's the
similarity trotter theorem and as a
corollary we see that end points end
lines give you at most n to the 4/3
interfaces in contrast to the setting of
the finite field plane where you can get
n to the 3 halves incidences so somehow
we have to use the topology of the real
plane for this one and I want to show
you a proof terms are not the original
proof but there's a proof that uses the
crossing number inequality to prove
similarity trotter theorem and you see
in crossing number inequality we are
using the topology of the real plane via
where Euler's formula very big very
beginning Oilers formula has to deal
with the topology of the real plane
now this bound turns out to be tight so
let me give you an example showing that
the 4/3 exponent is tight and the
example is
if you take P to be this rectangular
grid of points so rectangular grid of
points and L to be a set of lines so I'm
going to write the lines by their
equation where the slope is an integer
from 1 through K and the y-intercept is
an integer from 1 through K squared and
you see here that every line in L
contains exactly K points from peak so
we get in total K to the fourth
incidences which is on the order of n to
the 4/3 so n to the 4/3 is the right
answer
[Applause]
ok so now let me show you how to prove
some where they tottered theorem from
the crossing number inequality it turns
out to be very neat application that's
almost a direct consequence once you set
up the right graph and the idea is that
we are going to draw a graph based on
our incidence configuration so first
just to clean things up a little bit
let's get rid of get rid of lines and L
with 1 or 0 points so this operation
doesn't affect the bounds
so you can check these lines they don't
contribute much to the incidence bound
and only contributes to this plus L so
you can get rid of such lines
so let's assume that
every line in Elle contains at least two
points from P and let's draw a graph
based on this incident structure so if I
have suppose
okay so suppose these are my points and
lines I'll just draw a graph where I
keep the points as the vertices and I
put in an edge if it's a finite edge
that connects that connects two adjacent
points on the same line so I get some
graph let me make this graph a bit more
interesting so I get some graph and how
many crossings are noise does this graph
have so the number of crossings of G is
at most the number of lines squared
because a crossing comes from two lines
so here you have a crossing the crossing
comes from two lines number of crossings
are the most number of lines squared on
the other hand we can give a lower bound
to the number of crossings from the
crossing number in equality and to do
that I want to estimate a number of
edges and this is the reason why I
assume every line contains at least two
points from peep it's because I
with okay incidences gives K minus one
edges and if K is at least two and K
minus one is at least K over 2 let's say
I don't care about constant factors so
by crossing number inequality the number
of crossings of G is at least the number
of edges cubed over the number of
vertices squared which is at least the
number of incidences of this
configuration cubed over the number of
points squared number of vertices is the
number of points and a number of edges
by this argument here is on the same
order as the number of incidences
putting these two facts together so we
see okay there was one extra hypothesis
in crossing number in court right so
provided that this hypothesis holds
which is that the number of incidences
is at least eight times the number of
points so that the original hypothesis
holds okay so putting everything
together rearranging all of these terms
and using upper and lower bounds on the
crossing number we find that the number
of incidences its upper bounded by or
the main term you see is just coming
from these two
but there are a few other terms that we
should put in just in case this
hypothesis is violated and also to take
care of this assumption over here so
adding a couple of linear terms
correspond to the number of points and
the number of lines so that if this
hypothesis is violated then inequality
is still true okay so this proves the
crossing numbers inequality any
questions all right
so we've done this these two you know
very neat results but questions what do
they have to do with the sum-product
problem so I want to show you how you
can give some lower bound on the
sum-product problem using similarity
trotter theorem so it turns out that the
sum-product problem is intimately
related to incidence geometry and the
reason you'll see in a second precisely
why they're related but roughly speaking
when you have addition and
multiplication they are kind of like
taking slope and y-intercept of an
equation of a line so there are two
operations that are involved so turns
out many incidents geometry proms can be
set up in a way so many some product
problems can be set up in a way that
involves incidence geometry and a very
short and clever lower bound to the sum
product problem was proved by allocation
in the late 90s
so he showed the bank that if you have a
subset finite subset of reals then be
some set size times the product set size
is at least 8 to the 5 half as a
corollary one of these two must be
fairly large the max of the some set
size and the product set size is at
least 8 to the 5 let me show you the
proof I'm going to construct a set of
points and a set of lines based on the
set a and a set of points in R 2 is
going to be pairs X comma Y where the
horizontal coordinate lies in some set a
plus a and the vertical coordinate lies
in the products at a time say and a set
of lines is going to be these lines y
equals to a times X minus B I should say
X minus a prime where a and a prime lie
so these are some points and some lines
and I want to show you that they must
have many incidences so what are the
incidences so note that the line y
equals to a times X minus a prime it
contains the points
a prime plus B and a B which lies in p4
all hey so you plug it in you plug in a
prime plus B into here you get April and
this point lies in P because the first
coordinate is in the sum set the second
coordinate biasing the product set so
each drawing L contains many incidences
right so each lying L contains a
incidence so this line each line
contains a incidences also we can easily
compute the number of lines and a number
of points a number of points is a plus a
size x times the number of lines is just
the size of a squared so by similarity
quarter we find that the number of
incidences is lower bounded by noting
this fact you you have many incidences
so the number of lines each line
contributes a incidences but we also
have an upper bound coming from this
summer Eddie Trotta theorem plugging in
the upper bound we find that you have so
now I'm just directly plugging in the
statement of similarity totter
the main term is the the first term you
should still check the latter two terms
but the main term is the first term so
now plugging in the values for P and L
we find this is the case plus some
additional terms which you can check our
dominated by the first term so let me
just do a big ol over there now you put
left and right together and we could
obtain some lower bound the product of
the sizes of the sunset and the products
set there by yielding allocation so this
is some lower bound on the sum product
problem and we see we went through the
crossing number inequality to prove
similarly trotter a basic result in
incidence geometry and viewing some
product as an incidence geometry problem
one can obtain this lower bound over
here any questions I want to show you a
different proof that was found later
that gives an improvement and question
can you do better than than 5/4 so it
turns out that there was a very nice
result of show emotion sometime later
that gives you an improvement
so emo she proved in 2009 that if a is a
subset of positive reals then the size
of a time say multiplied by the size of
a plus a squared is at least size of a -
4/4 ceiling log of the size of a where
the log is spaced - okay so don't worry
about a specific constants a being in
the positive Rios's no big deal because
you can also you can always separate a
positive and negative and analyze each
part separately so as a corollary to
show emotions theorem we obtain that for
a subset of the reals the sunset and the
product set at least one of them must
have size at least a raise to 4/3
divided by 2 times log base 2 size of a
raised to one-third so basically a to
the 4/3 - the tall one in the exponent
so better than before and this is a new
bank I want to note that in this
formulation where we're looking at lower
bounding this quantity over here this is
tight up to logarithmic factors by
considering a to be just the interval
from 1 to n right hey it's the interval
from 1 to n then the left hand side a
plus a's around size n so you have n
squared + 8 times a is also I mentioned
around size N squared so so this
inequality here is tight the consequence
is not height
the first inequality is tight okay so
the remainder of today's lecture I want
to show you how to proof show emotions
lower bound and it has some similarities
to the one that we've seen because it
also looks at some geometric aspects of
the sum-product problem but it doesn't
use the exact tools that we've seen
earlier it does use some tools that were
related to the lecture from yesterday if
I'm from Monday so last time we
discussed this thing called the additive
energy we can come up with a similar
notion for the multiplication operation
or so the multiplicative energy cleaner
energy which will denote by a
multiplication symbol hey so the
multiplicative energy is like the
additive energy except that instead of
doing addition we're going to do
multiplication instead so one way to
define it is it's the number of
quadruples such that there exists some
comes some real lambda such that a comma
B equals to lambda C comma D so
basically the same as additive energy
except that we're using multiplications
instead by the Cauchy Schwarz inequality
and this is an equality this is a
calculation we saw last time as well we
see that if you have a set with small
product then it must have high
multiplicative energy so last time we
saw so small subset implies high
additive energy
likewise small small products that
implies high multiplicative energy
particular
the multiplicative energy of a you can
rewrite it as sum over all elements X in
the product set of the quantity which
tells you the number of ways to write X
as a product this number squared and
summed over all X by cauchy-schwarz we
find that this quantity here is lower
bounded by the size of a to the fourth
divided by the size of a times a so to
prove show emotions theorem we are going
to actually prove a bound on the energy
instead of proving it on the product set
you can prove it on the energy so it
suffices to show that the multiplicative
energy is at most four times the sum set
size x okay so let me divide the energy
by log of a click this into this
inequality you would imply the theorem
so it remains to show this inequality
over here upper bounding the
multiplicative energy
there's an important idea that we're
going to use here which is also pretty
common in the analysis is that instead
of considering that energy sum here
we're going to consider okay so a
similar Psalm except we're going to chop
up the sum in two pieces according to
how big the terms are so that we're only
looking at contributions of comparable
size and so this is called a dyadic
decomposition the idea is that we can
write the multiplicative energy similar
to above but instead of summing over X
in the product set let me sum over s in
the quotient set okay so you can
interpret what this a quotient a is so
this is the set of all a divided by B
where a and B are a is a set of positive
real so I don't need to worry about
division by zero so what the mains then
is the intersection of s times a a
squared remember s times a is scaling
each element of a by s you have this
quantity over here so I want to break up
the sum into a bunch of smaller sums
where in I want to break up the sum
according to how big the terms are so
that inside each group all the terms are
roughly of the same size and I way to do
this is to chop them up into groups
where everything inside the same
collection of differs by a most a factor
of two so that's why it's called a
dyadic decomposition going from i from
zero to the maximum possible here is
basically a so let's look at I going
from 0 to log base 2 of a so this is the
number of pins and each and partition
this sum into sub sums where I'm looking
at the I sub sum consisting of
contributions involving terms with sides
between 2 to the I and 2 to the I plus 1
so break up the sum according to the
sizes of their summons by pigeonhole
principle one of these summons must be
somewhat large so by pitching hole there
exists okay such that setting D to be
the SS such that that corresponds to so
the K term in this sum
so one has that this some coming from
just contributions from deep yes at
least so it's at least the
multiplicative energy divided by the
number of bins
oh damn in deep insight by pigeonhole I
can find one bin that's that's pretty
large contribution to the sum and the
right hand side we can upper bound each
term in this each term over here by two
to the 2k plus 2 and the number of times
the size of deep let me call the
elements of ds1 through SM where s 1 to
s n are sorted in increasing order okay
now let me draw you a picture
what's going on let's consider for each
element of D ok so for each I in M let's
consider the line given by the equation
y equals to s sub I times X where I'm
looking at the positive quadrant so I
have a bunch of points in the positive
quadrant
and specifically I'm interested in these
points whose coordinates both
coordinates are elements of eight and I
want to consider lines through points of
a but I want to consider lines where it
intersects this a cross a in the desired
number of points and you know we find
those set and then let's draw these
lines over here where this line here l1
it has slope exactly s1 and l2 l3 and so
on okay I want to draw one more line
which is so more auxilary but just to
make our life a bit easier
finally let's let L of M plus 1 be the
vertical line or rather be the vertical
ray which goes through the minimum
element of a above L M so it's this line
over here okay a cross a I draw a bunch
of lines so not all the lines so all
these lines involve some point of a and
the origin but I don't all of them I
draw a select set of them and what we
said earlier says that the number of
lines the number of points on each of
these strong lines is roughly the same
for each of these lines
okay let's let capital L sub J denote
the set of points in a cross a that lie
on the J spline so that's 1 2 and so on
I claim that if you look at Q
consecutive lines and look at the some
set of the points in a cross a that they
intersect okay you're looking at two
lines are you adding a points on those
two lines so you form a grid so you end
up forming this grid and the number of
points on this grid is precisely the
product of these two point sets
moreover the sets lj+ hello sub J +1 are
disjoint for different J and this is
okay so this is where we're using the
geometry of the plane here because the
sum of l1 and l2 lies in this span the
sum of l2 and l3 lies in a different
span so they cannot intersect since they
span disjoint regions so l1 plus l2 lies
here L 2 plus L 3 plus there and so on
so they are all disjoint ok now let's
put everything that we know together
remember the goal is to upper bound the
multiplicative energy as as a function
of the sum so in other words we wanted
lower bound the sum set so I want to
show you that this a plus a has a lot of
elements there's a lot of sons and have
a bunch of disjoint contributions to
these sums so let's add up those
destroying contributions to the sons
see that the size of a plus a squared
it's the same as the size of the product
set a plus a okay so this is Cartesian
product this is Cartesian product in
other words the grid that is strung up
there I add this product to itself
so I should get the same set here how
big is this sum sector so that grid that
lattice quit added to itself how big
should it be I want the lower bound the
number of sums and the key observation
up there we can look at contributions
coming from distinct spans so in
particular this sum here is that this
subset here size is lower bounded by
these distinct l j plus l j plus once I
throw away a lot I only keep the lines
on the else and the only consider sums
between consecutive else that should be
a lower bound to the some set of the
grid with itself but you see okay and
here we're using that these different
for different J's these contributions
are disjoint but by what we said up
there LJ + LJ + 1 this a grid so it has
size our J times J plus 1 and the size
of each LJ is at least 2 to the K
so the sum here is at least M times 2 to
the 2k but we saw over here that the
energy lower bounds there's two to the
2k so we have a lower bound that is
multiplicative energy of a divided by
four times the log base two of the size
of eight
okay so don't worry so much about the
constant factors it's just the warder of
magnitude that is important and that's
it yep okay great questions how do we
what do we know about the size of Big L
sub M plus 1 okay so that's a good point
easiest answer is if I don't care about
these constant factors I don't need to
worry about it right you can think about
what then what is the number of points
on this line above it's essentially the
number of elements of a above the
biggest element of SM above SM yes the
it's a good question I think we don't
need to worry about it so I'm being
slightly sloppy here
so I think the question is how do we
know you know for J equals to M you have
this bound over here oh great okay so
yes
okay so there's some ways to do it like
you can notice that the vertical line
has at least as many points as the first
slanted line okay anyway so I details
that you can work out okay so this
proofs show moshus theorem which gives
you a lower bound on the sum set and the
product set sizes the maximum of those
to see it's based on it's this very
short it's very clever it took a long
time to find and it gave a bound the sum
product problem of 4/3 that actually
remained stuck for a very long time
until just fairly recently there was a
improvement that gifts so by Konya gone
and screwed off where they improved
showing Moshe banned from 4/3 to 4/3
plus some really small constant see some
explicit constant I think right now so
that's being proved over time but right
now I think C is around 1 over thousand
or a few thousandths so it's some small
but explicit constant it remains a major
open problem to improve the span and
proof errors similarity conjecture that
if you have n elements then one of the
sums or products must be nearly
quadratic in size and people generally
believe that that's the case any
questions okay
so so this concludes all the topics I
want to cover in this course so we went
a long way I said the beginning of this
course we started with extremal graph
theory looking at the basic problem of
if you have a graph that doesn't contain
some sub graph triangle see for what's
the maximum number of edges in fact I
showed up even today and then we went
down to other tools like SEM radix
regularity lemma that allows us to
deduce important arithmetic consequences
such as Roth's theorem it's also an
extremal problem if you have a set
without a three time arithmetic
progression how many elements can in
have and so the important twelve
similarities regularity lemma then later
showed up in many different ways in this
course especially the message of
similarity circularity lemma that when
you look at an object it's important to
decompose it into its structured
component and its pseudo-random
component so this dichotomy this
interplay between structure and pseudo
randomness is a key theme throughout
this course and it showed up in some of
the later topics as well when we
discussed spectral graph theory quasi
randomness graph limits and also in the
later Fourier analytic proof of Ross
theorem all of these proofs all of these
techniques involve some kind of
interplay between structure and pseudo
randomness in the past month or so we've
been looking at Freeman's theorem this
key result in additive combinatorics
concerning the structure of sets under
addition and there we also saw many
different tools that came up and also
connections I mentioned a few lectures
ago connections to really important
results in geometry two new group theory
and it really extends all around and a
few takeaways from this course in the
one event is that graph theory additive
combinatorics they're not isolated
subjects they're connected to a lot
within mathematics and that's one of the
goals I want to show you in this course
is to show these connections throughout
mathematics and
some to analysis the geometry tat
apology and even simple questions can
lead to really deep mathematics and some
of them I try to show you try to hint at
you or at least I mentioned throughout
this course and what we've seen so far
and is just the tip of the iceberg right
so and there's a lot of still extremely
exciting work that's been done and I've
also try to emphasize many important
open problems that yet to be better
understood and I expect that in some
future iteration of this course some of
these problems will be resolved and I
can show the next generation of students
in your seats
some new techniques new methods and new
theorems and I expect that will be the
case this is a very exciting area and in
the area that is very close to my heart
it's something that I've been thinking
about since my PhD notice this bulk of
my research work revolves around better
understanding connections between graph
theory on one hand and additive
combinatorics on the other hand it's
been really fun teaching this course and
happy to have all of you here
[Applause]